ah Citizens Bank Park a house of horrors
for opposing teams this postseason until
tonight it is The Closer on TBS
presented by Genesis and you are invited
Jimmy Rollins how you living Curtis
Granderson jrro Jimmy Rollins P Martinez
the Hall of Famer my name is Lauren
shotti the Diamondbacks got some Moxy
the theme with them this postseason they
don't care where they're playing the
almighty Dodgers the almighty Phillies
they drive nice cars too Curtis wo they
get paid checks just like everybody else
and they needed aggressive behavor
Behavior like Tori said it's still wrote
right here we finally got some
aggressive behavior and that's why we
have a game seven that's what I said in
the pregame show I said Pedro they're
not stealing any bases he said Lauren
it's tough against these pitchers but
they were more themselves tonight Pedro
yes they they were an absolute chaos
like like they say uh the chaos I I I
think I saw now what Tori was really
talking about and what he meant I saw a
different game today and and a different
approach which maybe because they saw
Nola and they were able to have enough
time to study what they did uh one other
thing that I saw with a very very uh
positive and and and kind of a cocky
attitude that Tori said we didn't fly
all the way over from the west coast to
the east coast to to get our bleep
kicked
it our butt kick our butt so I I I I was
extremely happy to finally see Arizona
play the game that they were that they
meant to play the entire postseason and
Tori kept talking about it kept talking
about it but we never saw it and in
reality they never had an opportunity to
to have one of those starters lead a
game and they did it today against Nola
and they ended up getting the win by
causing all sorts of chaos like they say
and it was home run back to back that's
what we usually see the Phillies do they
were able to kind of Silence the crowd
early and let Merl Kelly settle in
definitely they was big getting out that
first inning we saw Trey just miss miss
a home run which would have put I think
a two-run home run at the time and that
changed the whole attitude of that team
they came out went bop bop everybody's
on their on their heels like what the
heck just happened and this is what
they've done all season long we haven't
seen this type of play from them since
the Dodger series but they were able to
do that tonight why were they able
because they forced the issue they
didn't sit back and wait for it to come
to them yes if they get a lead they got
a nice early lead but they kept pushing
they kept pushing pushing runs across
getting hit after hit timely hit with
runs in scoring position that's how you
play Arizona Diamond Back baseball they
saw it tonight and tell you what they
may not have been ready for Philly the
first time around but they wern't coming
out there to play no games tonight and
Tommy fam back in the lineup Tory lell
changing up the lineup throwing
everything at the Philadelphia Phillies
and credit to Merill Kelly the two
seamer down in early that late movement
I don't know how anyone gets a hit in
the big league did you hear M cury at
the end but I asked him why he was y you
know upset I wanted to go after
schwarber Turner and Harper they were 0
for n against him I'm dominating let me
go back at him again don't take me out
they're not touching me right now it was
that swag it was that aggression I'm
going at him let me go and do my thing
well I mean he powered through the three
best hitters he got him in that fifth it
was schwarber it was Turner and it was
Harper and then the camera panned to him
and lllo and lllo shook his hand and
he's going are you kidding me what were
you thinking in that moment well I I
went back to Loria and I went back back
to uh uh the young rookie pitching an
outstanding game and I was really upset
at Tori for doing that and he actually
admitted to that he says am I disgracing
the game by not following what I know
well but guess what after listening to
Longoria explained to us that they had
the plan the entire season for those
guys to use them that way it it seems
like it's coming from the front office
the entire season they're sticking to to
that plan and to be honest it's paying
off it is we criticized him with
fought we criticized it today and it
worked in both games yeah in every game
every move they have made seems to be
the same they pull out the picture when
they feels right and then they go with
their bin and that's how they have done
it and they're forcing a game seven for
that let me ask you this because we talk
about this all the time full pin getting
exposed if F goes out there tomorrow and
has a game seven the way he had game
three do you let him ride because he was
filthy he wasil did not know who he was
but now you have a pedigree you've seen
that the kid has done it before so now
you can trust it even more but they've
been doing it all season long they
they've trusted guys all season long do
you still use that in a game seven I I I
I don't to be honest I'm an old school
guy when it comes to that I would use my
baseball experience and IQ to to tell if
I take him out early enough or I leave
him in there but as you saw today both
teams were trying to just navigate
Innings Lorenzen was able to do an
outstanding job on the pH side to to
stop the bleeding and give them a chance
to come back but uh kudos to the Arizona
Diamond Backs they were better today
from the buen than they were in the
previous game managing and a game seven
forget it I want no part of that's like
like the wild card game right the
bullpen moves are Paramount and we're
going to see it in prime time tomorrow
night on TBS 8:00 p.m. eastern time your
first pitch on Tuesday win or go home
there is nothing better than game seven
we will have it for you on TBS you
pitched in game sevens Pedro twice right
what's it like what's your mindset well
you know that that all the effort that
you you did as a team uh falls into your
shoulders is a huge responsibility but
one that you want to have why because
you're the best suited for that game
that day and uh even though you you you
you have such a pressure on top of you
because you think about your teammates
and how much work they have put into the
entire season to get to that point to
get to a game seven and you don't want
to let them down but at the same time
you have to say the reason I'm here is
because they believe I am the one best
suited to give them an opportunity to
win it's such a good point you think
about the Phillies they were just here
they had to go home and then they had to
go back in March to the back fields at
spring training and this is what they've
dreamt of since that moment in time
Jimmy well I'm not sure they dreamt of
game seven I'm sure they were they were
dreaming of popping bottles right now
but if you're the Phillies you have to
feel like you're in good shape you know
with Ranger and that's why it's so funny
the coolest guy probably on a team just
just almost like he has no heartbeat he
just got out the cold tub and was like
I'm ready who's more calm you or Ranger
Suarez I me I was calm with smooth with
two different things smooth for show
something about you know what I'm saying
put it with it cool and collected when
he went to the bullpen I was thinking
where's Ranger sarez and I'm thinking
what the heck am I talking about they
need him for game seven in a major way
they need him and he's need to be ready
and not only him but the Philly fans
they talked about it ahead of time it's
being nicknamed decible City well the
Diamond bags came in and turned that
volume down quick so they got to come
out intense rocking all day ready to go
and bring that Philly intensity from
Pitch one and somehow try to get back
after the diamond cuz the Diamondbacks
were able to get them and get everyone
to sit in their seats and that's what
made them comfortable that's what made
them aggressive and that's why we have
game seven oh I love deciel City you
need it you need a t-shirt with that on
tonight that's right